please welcome the cast
it was the most fun watching you all
watch this stuff and who seemed to love
the show as much as we all do which is
great to see we have a little bit fun
let me let me know immediately - [ __ ]
who has some things to tell you first
off I'd like to say thank you everybody
for being here this is an incredible
derivative to hear you guys your
enthusiasm of the show it's just awesome
so we really appreciate you being here
today we want to just give a shout out
very quickly to Ari who is he's always
on the con floor and we just couldn't
find him he's working towards
he really really wanted to be here he's
but he's carrying the flag back and then
half the beach and just a couple of
really quick announcements that we're
really really excited to be making today
the first is after super I have a super
super the super girl premiere on October
26 we are going to have a very special
episode where people to Vienna which
will be 90 minutes long they will go
8:30 to 11 o'clock and scorpion is going
all so just remember that
set your DVRs tend to be an incredible
big big episode force and also we'd like
to announce one more thing in our first
episode coming up our premiere we're
going to have a very special cameo from
someone who is major abroad all-star was
on the cotton floor signing over the
next few days is gene Simmons will be
with so have you seen him
please outside you are to see him as is
on the other team scorpion so I just
want to thank everybody again and turn
can come to you very that it's a listen
I have a bunch of questions to ask those
guys but you all have questions I want
to make sure you get your chins so I'm
throwing the script away you guys let's
get your questions can we do that line
up if you have a question I'm going to
start off just by will go down belonging
starting at the end with Patrick and
asking you who is the smartest person
that you know the smartest person that I
know there are correct answers yeah it's
uh well then we hit it Kate Thomas is a
smart guy I think we're all very
annoying the rest of us a lot of rage if
I'm on the machine movie in these
clothes that's a good it this is not a
problem
oh just to Ramona
cabinets the smartest person that you
know had one take one maybe to you I was
going to say making center for creating
scorpions okay
I'll definitely say J one but I would
also say takes interest incredibly
insulting human being he wasn't smart
enough to be here because he had to work
goodbye Thomas a credit where these are
concerns now we have a life great what
is your name forget that my gun TriNet
my name is dawn what is reversible is
for a Robert Patrick G on a planet sir
turn to the tournaire
I do not I do not very very happy doing
scorpion and want to continue doing it
for many many years what is your name I
think I could turn your mic on hello try
go ahead try it I'm Mac and what is your
name what is your question man um so you
guys are all geniuses on the show
what was your worst subject right now
for me with man not the remembers school
was difficult
tumbling we see on TV school Holland
schools interest of science i renovated
momentum again yeah Jane Holzer oh man
mouth Robert well I don't play a genius
but yeah math was pretty difficult for
me but what was the message expert was
there something that excited about
history
patience response America good evening
America
yes hi my name is green shade and my
question is how did you guys feel when
you were doing all the action scenes I
did you feel scared did you feel like
you couldn't do it
look at let me ask first come on you had
done it actually seen the path problem
of course we know that you know but had
anyone anyone else done actually the
scenes not asked for yes so for those of
you who are new to it how did you find
that stuff sometimes it's as terrifying
as it looks it's pretty crazy stuff we
have an amazing crew that puts together
all that stuff you saw and whether we're
you know jumping out of a moving plane
or holding cat down and long hair
feeling chef it's it's crazy all
thinking but we work so hard that just
put our trust in this amazing crew and I
think they do a pretty damn good job I
mean just watching that all those stunts
I was it looks like a great movie and
that's what's really exciting about show
together a great action movie every week
any mama toxin you guys are a little
afraid when you're riding in the car
with me yes Marta do it for me I promise
dry air reckless driver
I'm a little reckless actually
well-trained
in the end a sound of course was the
races like the Long Beach Grand Prix
Toyota pro/celebrity race I think they
think cyber you're good about the Bijoux
shooting so then no one else could have
been injured my generation but that's
the only time I see you guys get afraid
learn their fuel screw other think let
me ask you this
are there things that you guys
discovered as writers the first season
that the cast is capable of that may be
surprised you or that you enjoy writing
for them or little things that you're
opening for them Wow I mean so many
things we learn I mean we that they're
funny and it's so of me that we knew
that some were funny we kind of all work
and everybody do comedy
everybody could nail those jokes and
especially if those you know in these
action booms that you're talking about
we can get amazing you know we can get
some amazing heroes and then everybody
was also didn't stuff and I don't have
were terribly comfortable with it but we
were thrilled about them in those
situations because they were so great
everything turned out you know we were
we were just doused with how far we can
push things ultimately production-wise
that was sort of close shocking to us
but we just kept pushing it further and
that's what we plan to do for season two
is just
right is a question Wagner what is your
name I'm Micah when I'm playing with my
question to you is was the biggest part
of yourself that you see in your
character let's start you legit let me
let me ask you this I'm going to
rephrase that
or beforehand um you know your character
Abby has sort of become this super
heroine I'm sort of a symbol of
empowerment especially a female in power
was this unexpected to you or what do
you think you bring to this character
that people are responding to because
yeah it's funny because when people
brought that up seeing happy as this
figure like strong female figure that
sort of it kind of took me for surprise
because for me when I read happy off the
page
I loved herbaceous women she's you know
she's she can pause on the edge is like
this sort of look is actually Harold but
there's flaws which is essentially you
know that's that's all of us and um to
answer the second part it's like I think
that's what people relate to
it's she's got a weakness who's in it
but that doesn't stop her and she
doesn't let that drive it down yeah
she's a complicated character you
excited character anywhere by the wood
how are you like your characters it
mostly had bass I it's all right
I am as excited being a part assisting
as Tobias when I show up to work every
day and we're doing all this crazy stuff
it's I think Toby goes into it like
really we're going to go to a shirt I
and I have the same law of the fact that
I'm doing it and I'm just amazed that
mean we get to be part of such crazy
adventures every week I've never done
anything like this he actually early on
the simpler than the earlier episode he
purposely didn't wear the hat as he
wanted to make sure you oh maybe a hair
yet bold to take I can't are you like
your character I would say I guess Paige
is a pretty perceptive person I guess
I've always kind of considered myself
some of you of leads lose and just
different vibes like just different
rooms and I'm getting a good feel for
kind of what's going on and so I've got
a lot of high quality though they're
kind of are sensitive to serve just
people in general so I might mean that
you need to also surprisingly though
both you and your characters safe that
is that's true
will we get to see more singing you
suppose in season two I'm not easily be
seen pasting more than there's gonna be
a lot of
they're made they're a you know you
never know older people thought that was
my idea was it to have like a same thing
thing make you know what it wasn't no
I'm surprising yeah well where I was
about surprised that's all right
Lia's how you like your character I was
just thinking about it for about in a
few seconds as you're going down the
line I kind of I don't struggle because
obviously we're playing the characters
that we are because we have something
that these great creators who create the
show thoughts about a window casting us
but I am I think that the nice thing
about Walter that we were exploring or
trying to explore is that as much of a
mirror or a barrier to emotions that he
is displaying to other people on there
is a huge amount there is a huge
emotional vault that does have it's just
in terms of the conveyance for how he
shows you to other people that's the
disparity so I feel that it really does
have a lot of emotional depth and he
really feels a lot and you know I hope
on the second thing an observing so I
have three point of the showrunners here
on a bound but we talked about this a
great deal and I think it's just in
terms of translating and
is very different from actually saying I
don't have it and I think I think that's
one of the parallels that I've
experienced is that he does have us and
you know I obviously have to feel good
things like he feels when he's in the
same from Wernham cares to hear about
how you are like Gabe but also how
McCain is different from other law
enforcement figures you're inflating the
Hat yeah he sort of a blended a lot of
different characters I have gone in from
the past and I'm a father real life and
I think that's what I'm focusing on more
so than anything is the fraternal
relationship we Walter up myself and
that's what I've been having the most
Marcus born actually and and growing
learning to accept that the other new
members of the group and starting to you
know develop relationships with them and
it's it's just such a great role I'm
having I don't have to think much about
all the
long and asked excellent yeah I think I
think we see a lot of your own work come
out in this camera
I hope shaking am an optimist Oh
I hope so of each case cos got a
good-hearted salt-of-the-earth kind of
guy I think you know he loves his
country and he wants to do the right
thing i real time for a couple more
questions what is your name where's my
question is so aged warrior have a
weight warrior Quintus and there we must
rummy I love the fact that these guys
have no idea how to navigate their loved
ones I basically know and I suppress
this we have to relate to but yeah
that's one of my favorite parts being on
the show is that these guys you know
stop nuclear bombs from falling on Los
Angeles and saved tens of thousands of
lives but they don't know how to relate
to each other and I think you know from
tobe happy it's this thing that they're
feeling and they want to make it happen
but there that's the one part of
themselves that they just can't figure
out and maybe it's stronger for these
guys then for the average person but I
think that's something we can all relate
to is not knowing how to navigate
through the
romance love and just general social
anxiety I think we all have that look
how do you guys in the writers room find
the balance between those relationship
stories and the procedural story is the
kind of general camaraderie in stories
that we like to say I mean we those are
probably the most fun things for us to
write I mean it's to to see the
interactions because that's the side of
yeah that's the side of these characters
in which they are really valid you know
the a side of adventures that they
really are they're racing against the
clock it's so dangerous there's so much
at stake but on the B side of it you
know so there's today and they have
their really good track records they're
pretty much perfect but on the B side
they really are bad they're really bad
at their relationships they're really
sort of incredibly fallible and that's
what I think makes those a side stories
really work is to see those who knows to
see these guys struggling through their
just the standard you know dating
rituals that some people find
nice everyday but that guy thinks the
stuff that we it makes the unit thinks
the a side of this channel work well is
it the B side is so human so it's a lot
of functions in restricted to bring our
own you know our own sort of craziness
into the show switch is a lot of fun for
everyone what is your name hi my name is
Nicole when I guess this question was
already answered but which of you had
the hardest time relating to your
character was there a learning curve on
the show for you guys I mean there's
obviously it feels like even from the
very first episode you all knew we might
be jump but obviously that wasn't the
case didn't know each other I don't know
if you liked each other both on that
learning curve just as far as figuring
out each other in the world of your own
characters it's been a lot of behind the
scenes we spend a lot of time together
it takes a long time to make this show
and you know there's six of us so
there's just a lot of a lot across
dynamics I was terrified of Robert
Patrick when I
are you still I guess
they live on in trouble physically but
you know I have we're just learning how
to screw with each other a lot and we
can bring that on screen that we like to
mess around a lot on set and you know my
banter with Robert J you know you're
seeing a lot of that real-life
relationship in the way we've messed
with each other on TV so it's I'm sad we
were doing it was that difficult to get
to the beginning but it's just we found
all these new fun things
especially that we have a second season
we just keep on going I think we have
time for one more what is your name
hi I'm Alex so I'm a very big fan of the
show so I would like to ask to all the
kings up there on the way you're my
favorite jacket I love Jack so go you
you're saying wrong
anybody ii have to change it
thank you well IRA question what do you
guys do and get more Jardim to content
with on the kazoo erm yeah we we
research all that stuff very careful to
make sure that it's all as you know
definite and then try to get
pronunciation K sometimes to make sure
because it's very complicated stuff at
all and everything says the queue is
just get it done fast ripped right
through but it was interesting isn't it
through just talking a little bit about
a longer period to deal with a show like
this the thing is just talking about
those please car burns and about the
fact that we we create like a family
action stroke show many other type of
different shows into one that you really
devote those bits of a breath and you
know the loan sort of a spectrum of
emotion within the scene when you do run
like like
run those seams as hard and quick
because it's about creating you guys
always create another character when
when we create that that pace and that
um swiftness of communication between
and it also means a lot to do with how
we relate to each other you've got the
two other characters decidedly
Katherine Roberts characters that in the
middle of this they had their own
expertise but to see them inclusion as
conduits but our switch person
communication really adds another
dimension to it it feels like sorry I
have to carry questions before we wrap
up um I guess this is a question for
Nick are we going to see a super fungi
comic book spin-off a superbike echoes
in a shell right
we're doing a lot of stuff actually
super fun guy
this year we really it's become one of
the funnest things that I think that
were that we're doing until we are going
to have there's definitely more super
fun guy you're going to see some super
fun guy coming certainly out of the
supergroup premiere into our show it
would be we're going to sort of link
into their their mythology live into our
mythology so we have some plans but a
dumb show you know can start with a
common exact and then are you guys all
aware of and have to plate the scorpion
drinking game circus they really smoking
for dying are tolling when when people
hear the word algorithm on the show
what does
get around walls
you